oh hi welcome to ask IJ yeah some
questions here my phone from you guys
from Twitter I'm also wearing camo again
x I love I just eat excellent snowball
ever do an apartment or house tour video
the problem with that is every time I go
to shoot a video of my house or my
apartment it gets so messy because I'm
just I'm a pig I'm a slob if I was a pig
in a pigpen I would probably I know
where I'm going with this Kayla wants to
know which console i'm most excited
about xbox 720 or playstation 4 i'm most
excited for xbox because i love xbox
most my friends have xbox and it's kind
of a console that I've just kind of been
playing forever I will probably get the
PlayStation 4 because I'm sure there's
gonna be exclusive games that I'm going
to want to play on there and not be able
to play if I don't have a PlayStation so
celebrate new games come home Silas of
the one day I set up to the dye my hair
dark do you know when that's gonna be
ooh I don't know I feel like this is a
good color I like it feel like one day
I'm gonna go crazy Miley status and just
do a nice little chop maybe not so far
as the britney here actually I probably
would shave my head I wouldn't even
think twice about it to be completely
actually that's a lie i would think a
few times either like or i wouldn't i
don't know i had too much coffee today
which camera do i use for my video
recording or live streaming for live
streaming I just use my Mac eyesight and
right now i'm using the canon xa10 and
sometimes i use the canon 60d depending
upon how lazy i am if i use this camera
it focuses by itself if i use the i'm
pointing to it like you guys can see it
hold on if i use the DSLR it's really
hard because I'm this is what I have to
do hold the camera picture this on a
tripod look kind of any pull something
like that is a little
sometimes doesn't work out so well but
this camera is great did I answer your
question I think I did so close fitting
for a good long how long does usually
take for you to make a video depending
on the video it can take anywhere from
an hour to four or five six seven eight
nine ten hours why do I love iPhones are
Apple so much and when did this interest
start my love of Apple has pretty much
been my entire life I grew up with Apple
computers my mom's a teacher so back
then so my mom got our family one and
I've been obsessed ever since but as far
as the iphones go i actually went to the
launch of the first iphone to the mall
of america and i didn't even have enough
money to be able to buy one of the
iphones so i basically stood in line and
kind of enjoyed the iphone experience
through everyone else's excitement i was
so excited I even just recently found
this video of Joe who was the first guy
in line and I just watched as he opened
his iphone or like oh my god this is
amazing and you can see this video I'm
my old sprint palm treo and I'm like
tweeting and texting and oh my god it
was so much fun d Nobles that's we've
ever get pre-flight jitters think I may
have a small amount of narcolepsy and if
you don't know what that is it's where
you kind of just uncontrollably fall
asleep I get so sleepy sometimes that I
cannot even keep my eyes open especially
on flights or car rides I sit down on a
plane every time without fail and just
pass out I don't even get the snacks
Jeff wants to know what is your question
as a fellow gamer what's your opinion on
the whole blaming violent video games
for today's crime here's what I had to
say about that people cannot take
responsibility for their actions no
matter what just because you play a
video game doesn't mean you're gonna go
out and kill someone let me tell you
what I've been playing video games my
entire life violent video games at that
and I have not killed a single person I
don't want to go there thank you guys so
much for watching I look forward to
seeing you in my next video don't forget
to like this and subscribe i'll see you
guys the next video
I